foreign
Huntsville Alabama what's up Tim
hey Dr John how's it going good man hey
Alabama's hit on Hard Times man
had a chance to really watch much
football recently but yeah it's been
kind of a I think that's probably it's
probably better for you yeah
so what's up man
me and my wife and our relationship and
boundaries between uh her sister and her
boyfriend
your wife doesn't have a boyfriend
no her her sister has a boyfriend the
way you said you said between my sister
my between me and my wife and her sister
and her boyfriend I was like whoa yeah
okay so yeah full Alabama all right all
right all right all right okay
so your your your wife has a sister and
your wife's sister has a boyfriend okay
correct yes all right so bring it okay
um so I love my wife I feel like I'm
married to my best friend absolutely
adore her
um my mother-in-law and father-in-law
are awesome human beings they're so
supportive and generous
um but wait till it comes to but
yeah
um uh my wife's sister uh has was an
alcoholic early on in her life and that
really caused some problems with
um her relationship with my sister okay
and with her parents obviously
um and there's been a string of like
very bad decisions uh that led to those
strange relationships be specific man
she's stealing stuff is she like she
apparently got violent with my sister a
couple of times
um
basically completely disrespected any
rules that the parents had in the house
um I just hung out with the wrong people
but uh thankfully uh now she's been
sober for several years awesome and uh
she's got a job she's doing really well
herself
um but her boyfriend is a bit uh I I
call it like immature
um he struggles keeping a job
and kind of in in my opinion kind of
like mooches off of her
and is more like a child to her I guess
than an actual partner okay and they
live together
um but the whole dynamic here is where
the problem kind of arose with us is
we live uh in a central location between
the two so mother and father-in-law live
about two hours north of us
sister-in-law and brother or
sister-in-law and boyfriend
live about four hours south of us so
we're Central you're going to move to
the family you got to move
this is going to fall on you forever you
don't want him coming to stay with you
huh
yeah that's that's the thing is so me
and my wife we're uh very adamant about
our standards and our virtues we believe
that you know sex is only for marriage
and we shouldn't
um live together in a cohabitation
unless we're actually married okay and
we don't agree with what uh her sister
and boyfriend are doing but hold on hold
on has she invited you in for your
opinion
no she hasn't no okay I would spend zero
seconds for the rest of my life
considering that
oh yeah I definitely I definitely agree
like what they do in their own house
that's completely 100 up to them yeah uh
the problem that uh and I may be making
too big of a deal out of this but uh
they want to have Christmas at our house
because oh do you know what I'm sharing
a room
yeah that's that's kind of the thing and
on on my argument is if they want to
stay under our Roof then they would have
to stay in separate rooms my wife is
kind of split because
she sees
that aspect of it but we also want to
preserve the relationship there we don't
want to push them away
after these past few years where there's
been some healing in the relationship
there so let's let me let's back out of
this situation okay
um number one I appreciate you laying it
all out there okay that's awesome
um
I love hamburgers and I love barbecue
and I
um eat a ton of wild game it's just how
our family does things okay we also have
chickens and we eat eggs every day
yeah I also have a couple of friends who
I love and care about and they are Die
Hard vegans to the death I guess not to
the deaf to the death of the spinach
right no other deaths
I don't
show up with burgers at their house
because it's disrespectful it's rude
yeah and if I'm gonna go stay there and
they're gonna have dinner I don't say
Hey man can I bring it because I because
I don't because I'm wanna be better than
that my friendship to them is more
important than that okay
so I tell you that to tell you this
it's your home
and it's your boundaries
and it's your values
they as people visiting your home
get to make their choice
whatever that happens to be hey we just
don't believe in air conditioning
and that's just how we roll we just
don't believe in it you are welcome to
um
here's my buddy Todd came and stayed at
my house Todd would prefer that most of
his life he lives on Antarctica and in
on Antarctica in Antarctica
um he prefers the temperature when he's
sleeping to be about negative six and in
our house sounds like my kind of guy
yeah exactly I had about 65. he when he
stayed at my house it was great and he
took a mattress out of the guest room
and Drug it into like another room where
it was cooler and you know what I didn't
care and he didn't care he chose to stay
at my house and he knows that we don't
have it sub-arctic we just have it cold
right all that to say is this they're
visiting your house
they get to decide are we going to come
in with this set of rules if you start
compromising your values whatever they
may be
in this pseudo-protective
trying to preserve a relationship
where the whole thing ends up is in
resentment Ash
okay
so
I how old are you
I'm 28.
my my
here's what here's the one thing I'm
struggling with
is I feel maybe I'm out to lunch and
maybe it's just uh the way you and I are
just we just communicate differently but
it feels like there's a
superiority
and I would let the air out of that
um
you have might not have been an
alcoholic but I promise you've had your
struggles and you might not be a mooch
but I promise that there are ways you
could be a better and more connected
husband right so I would get rid of the
um my values are better than their
values okay
I would say
stick with your values whatever they may
be who cares they're yours it's your
house
and let other adults make their choices
whether they want to opt into those they
can also get a hotel they can also go
camping they can also laugh and make fun
of you and be like that's so dumb but
okay
and all is well
you see what I'm saying
if they choose
to not come then they have chosen not to
come
that should not impact your value
judgments
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah that makes sense
so I'm not gonna dude if you said we
don't walk on the carpet in my house
well I don't take my shoes off well now
we got a problem you get to choose
whether you come in my house or not
I don't believe that people who aren't
married should sleep in the same bed
cool
well I'm my girlfriend and I are coming
over to your house well you've got a
choice to make
see what I'm saying like I just want to
take all the air out of the drama
like I'm just I'm just not gonna
apologize for my values in my house
yeah and and that's kind of what I told
my wife is
if
if it was a value we would apply to our
future children say I feel like it would
apply to ourselves
anyone who comes to visit us like we
should be consistent not change the
rules for whoever
enters you know
if that's how y'all want to roll with it
man don't give it a second thought
okay and let the other adults in your
life make their choices
um they get to do that and expect people
to when they run up against your
boundaries and I've said this a million
times when they run up against your
boundaries they're gonna bang their head
on them they're gonna kick and scream
they're gonna yell and punch and kick
and see if those boundaries hold
and man I'm just not gonna lose sleep
over this is just who we are in our
house
um I've recently done some interviews
with people that
um people don't like
I actually have both sides of the aisle
and one of my core core values is
I'm always gonna have a conversation
with somebody
just as people I believe they have that
dignity and that right to have a
conversation I'm not above anybody and
so people are going to get to make their
choices I'm not going to listen to drone
anymore because he had a conversation
with so and so he was on somebody else's
show he did this that's knock your
lights out that's great
but as for me and my house we're people
who are hospitable and we have
conversations with everybody
because I got a lot to learn I'm still
figuring this thing out
so Tim don't apologize for your for your
boundaries be very clear and be very
direct and be very respectful you're not
better than you were with right not
lording over but with and hold firm
to who you and your wife want your home
to represent to who you're going to be
and be prepared to live with the
consequences of your values all values
have consequences
you're in the right place my brother